the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
my intention tonight is primarily to
provide you with some suggestions
framings that will help that will help
in your viewing of these two films and
will also at the same time reinforce and
extend some of the things I was saying
this afternoon about Hitchcock's work
more generally on about the recurring
preoccupations themes obsessions
strategies that are characteristic of
his work and I want to begin by adding
one note to what I did what I was saying
this afternoon you remember I began this
afternoon by talking about the
relationship between Hitchcock and what
I call the genius of the system
borrowing on that famous passage from
Andre Bazin
who said Hollywood is very interesting
and there are interesting directors but
why don't we talk about the genius of
the system the way the system itself
encourages or enables complex forms of
narrative and we've already talked
several times earlier in the course
about this topic but there's another way
in which one can think about this issue
with regard to Hitchcock and I think
it's helpful and clarifying so I want to
mention it again
one way to think about Hitchcock is to
think of the Hitchcock film as a kind of
genre unto itself right the Hitchcock
just like the Western or the screwball
comedy broadly Hitchcock belongs to the
to the broad category of what might be
well of two categories the the horror
film although the strange director of
horror he certainly is incredibly
influential in fact when he made psycho
he publicly announced this is my first
horror film even though there are
elements of horror earlier and it made
something of a publicity splash when he
said that so one way to understand
Hitchcock is to think of him as
participating in at least two categories
of genre or sub-genre that are more
widespread than Hitchcock's work itself
and we might call that the the the
horror film and the mystery film and
even that's a bit of an
oversimplification because within the
category of mystery you can have
different sort of sub sub categories one
of which is the sort of romantic
adventure of the sort that North by Nora
Northwest
the the the chase film starring Cary
Grant that that Hitchcock made that ends
with characters climbing across the face
of Mount Rushmore so that's one the sort
of action-adventure version of a mystery
story that that Hitchcock makes another
version other versions are are examples
of the films that we're seeing tonight
so but but the point my point is that
that although one could fit Hitchcock's
film into some sort of larger category
of mystery or or mr. mystery and
adventure or something of that kind
it's also the case that once you begin
to look closely at its costumes you can
see that there's such a profound almost
obsessional coherence in them they keep
returning again and again to those
dominant themes I talked about this
afternoon that one can see that they in
some sense constitute a kind of category
order of their own if we think of so if
we think of the Hitchcock as a kind of
as a kind of genre even within that
category we can discover immense
variation so that Hitchcock's example
itself becomes a kind of crystallized or
distilled example of the principle I've
been talking about all semester
concerning the way in which a a system
like the Hollywood system could and
gender variation even as it is also
committed to giving its audience
something that seems familiar that they
recognize that they're willing to attend
to week after week after week I think
the primary point is this in a system in
which you have an habitual a regular a
daily or a weekly relationship to the
material there have to be elements of
familiarity of repetition of a return to
two shared subjects and themes or you
wouldn't do it you would you would find
it intolerable every time you made what
was a routine or habitual connection to
a text if what it gave you was a
completely new experience which forced
forced you in some sense to begin at the
beginning and to figure everything out
for you you would find it you would find
it you would resist such an experience
it's one thing to go to a great
overwhelming theatrical experience once
or twice a year or once or twice a month
it's quite another thing to try to watch
King Lear every day or even every week
right and so the part of the difference
has to do with the nature what it means
to have an habitual rather than an
occasional connection to the to the
artwork and one of the fundamental maybe
the most important thing about the
Hollywood studio film and later the most
important thing about American
television narrative forms is the canoe
is the intimate regular routinized
connection that the viewer has with the
material and in the case of Hitchcock
what we can say is really from the very
beginning of his work to the end there
are these fundamental emotional and
strategic or technical coherences
resemblances that make virtually every
Hitchcock film a kind of commentary on
an earlier one and the two films you're
seeing tonight are a particularly rich
example of this so I hope you'll think
hard about the way in which they are
both profoundly different from each
other and also at the same time
strangely mysteriously profoundly
similar how they circle back on the same
kinds of obsessions and the same kinds
of problems and part of our pleasure in
looking at the two films is is the
simultaneous recognition of the
difference and the similarity well that
is an example in small compass of the
larger principle of popular aesthetics
that I was saying applies to the needs
to apply to the way in which we
understand the audience's relation to
the classic Hollywood film so as you're
watching these two films and thinking
about them think both about resemblances
and differences and you'll get some
sense of how much remarkable variation
can be is possible within what remains
certain familiar conventions
expectations expectations not only about
about the content of the text but also
about the way the text is organized
about its formal about its formal
features so what I'd like to do then is
say is say a couple of introductory
things about each of the films you're
going to see and if my if I'm able to
keep the time right maybe maybe we'll
pause for one clip maybe we won't
depending on how
how concise I'm able to be in my in my
arguments um you'll notice the shadow of
a doubt and rear window are a loom are
11 years apart and and I think that's
significant because one of the most
interesting ways to think about
comparing the two films is to think
about the way in which rear window
seizes on many of the preoccupations and
themes that are at the center of shadow
of a doubt but deals with them you know
in ways that one might say are even more
disturbing and profound that press more
deeply into the implications that are
mobilized in the earlier film and for
maybe that sounds too general and
abstract and mysterious let me be
specific about what I mean one example
is if in one of the most interesting
aspects of shadow of a doubt if you look
down to my Lex to the next to the last
item is what I call the subplot and the
subplot in in in in shadow of a doubt
involves essentially a kind of
subsidiary story about two very
ineffectual characters in this subplot
that the husband of the family has a
kind of made his main preoccupation when
he's not working at his bank is he he
has an ongoing conversation and sort of
reading group with his friend played by
Hume Cronyn both also as a diminutive
man also a man who seems to lack
masculine force he's short he's less
he's not aggressive and they spend their
time reading murder mysteries and they
spend their time trying to devise the
perfect murder I mean what's a part of
what's funny about this but also McCobb
in its own way is that while these two
sort of cape on like older men who stand
for a kind of impotent maturity a kind
of useless unattractive maturity they
spend their time in divert and their
diversion is to try to invent or imagine
murders and and ma'am when in fact a
real murderers and is living at the
heart of the family and young Charlie
herself is actually in danger even
though her father and no one around that
no one around her in the world
understands that that's the case
although the viewer comes to understand
it fairly early and even young Charlie
comes to a recognition of it before the
film is
/ so so in this subplot what's going on
is we have two sort of characters
playing at the diversion of murder and
finding more stories about murder a kind
of escape the and and and and in fact
one of them is actually trying to devise
the way to kill someone again and a way
to kill someone and get away with it and
what we're supposed to feel is that this
subplot is a reminder to us of the a
number of things but most disturbingly
and subversively it should be a reminder
to the audience of what the audience is
doing sitting and watching Hitchcock's
film because the equivalent of the
audience in the movie is art is one one
equivalent of the audience in the movie
are these two sort of foolish people who
were immersed in and and in some degree
surrounded by evil and authentic danger
are living out their silly diversions by
reading silly magazines about about
murder stories so it's a variation on
Hitchcock's obsession or deep deep
recurring interest in the space of
entertainment and what it means to want
to go to entertainments right and
there's a certain sense there's a
certain sense in which every single
Hitchcock film enables or or or or as
Gruber is grounded upon this experience
of sitting in the dark actually we look
sort of equivalent to what the Jimmy
Stewart character does in rear window
sitting in the dark anonymous peeping
watching the lives of other people right
and and so this and so there and and and
the idea is not only that you're
anonymous but in some sense there's
something sort of illicit about it as if
as if in the process of doing it you're
indulging what our base desires or base
or or at least not totally respectable
impulses but you're dead but you're
doing but you're doing it in a space of
comparative safety and and and and and
the place of anonymity so that the
subplot in shadow of a doubt in a
certain sense raises a self-conscious
questions about the nature of the
entertainment that we ourselves are
watching as audiences for the film right
and it's clearly a major dimension of
shadow of a doubt it's
the things that make shadow of a doubt a
rich movie it's a it's there's a kind of
cunning cynical complexity in it that
careless viewers orbit or very very
superficial viewers won't pick up on and
it's really possible I could really
imagine that there were viewers who came
away from shadow of a doubt fully
satisfied thinking oh yes evil has been
purged what a what a nice mystery story
never fully picking up on the dramatized
elements of the text which put in
question the ease with which we embrace
these forms of entertainment the ease
with which with which we accept murder
and mayhem as a form of diversion and
the full implicant some of the
implications of that for human nature
and for our ideas of entertainment
itself right so that that moment when
the in in strangers on a train when the
merry-go-round goes goes mad and becomes
an instrument of terror and murder is
another example of Hitchcock of
Hitchcock's interest in the complexity
and problematic the cop the problematic
nature of our connection to what we call
entertainment right and one of the
things you can see when you shift to
rear window is you can see how these
preoccupations have been distilled and
clarified because the entire film
becomes a meditation on the nature of
our voyeuristic impulses the entire film
becomes a story about about about seeing
and not being seen about about following
and about about shadowing people about
about about hidden impulses or potential
doubles of our of our own respectable
nature and and the way in which rear
window is self reflexive or self
conscious is much more systematic and
much more deeply embedded in the
experience of watching the film than was
the case with shadow of a doubt the same
theme the same self-consciousness the
same awareness of the problematic nature
of entertainment but now much more
systematically and fully integrated into
the formal and thematic nature of the
text so I love shadow of a doubt in many
ways I it's one of
favorite Hitchcock's but it's early
Hitchcock and you can feel the much
greater rigor with which Hitchcock has
begun to seize on the implications of
his own problematic relation to his
material and his audience's compromised
complicit relationship to the material
that Hitchcock mobilizes in his film so
so rear window is more systemic in some
sense more more more coherently
conscious of this element of its meaning
it's almost as if by the time we get to
the to the mature films of the of the of
the 50s and beyond that the period
between let's say 1951 in the early 60s
when Hitchcock did most of his grip most
all of his most powerful work is almost
as if we can see that the films of this
year of this era have a kind of double
significance that that they that all
these film all the films after shadow of
a doubt are partly about filmmaking
they're partly self-conscious attempts
to be meditations on the nature of
movies and on the and and it's almost as
if there's a kind of separate story a
separate plot there's the traditional
kind of mystery story that was that is
characteristic of many films but then
there's this ministery this separate
story it's the story of the filming the
story of the making of the film the
story the story or the drama of watching
itself the drama of the watching we
might call it the literary version of
this would be the drama of the telling
right there are literary but if you
think of a novel like a novella like
Conrad's Heart of Darkness I think I've
mentioned this before in the class
because it's such a clear example
but the story heart of heart of darkness
is really two stories it's the story of
of the narrator's trip up the Congo
River when he was a young man but it's
even more the story of his struggles to
tell the story 20 years later and when
you read heart of darkness naive readers
hate it well can't figure out why it's
taking so long and why it's taking the
narrator so long to get to the point but
of course the story is not primarily
even about the adventure he's trying to
talk about it's about the struggle to
tell the adventure and what one could so
that there's a kind of double plot in
that in that novella as there is in a
lot of great modernist fiction right
there isn't another way in a lot of
great modernist paintings where you're
aware not only of the subject of the
painting but of the materials that go
into the making of the painting right
you're I'm thinking of the great
impressionist and post-impressionist
painters right or of the painters who
would paint like like Monet's word
paints fifty versions of a haystack in
different lights or 30s two versions of
Rouen Cathedral in different lights at
different times of the day why well one
of the reasons is he's trying to say
that reality is not stable that the that
that Rouen Cathedral changes depending
upon the light depending upon the
weather depending upon my emotion when I
look at it right in other word reality
is much more complicated and so that
when we look at the Rouen Cathedral
paintings we're aware of paint we're
aware of
we're aware not just of the fact that a
cathedral is being represented we're
aware of the process whereby Monet what
went through that the the terrific labor
of capturing the the the image and you
can see there were a lot of a lot of
examples even on painting of the
thickness of the paint when you look at
when you look at Monet's paintings very
often the paint is so thick that you
want more if you see it in reality you
want to reach out and touch it so that
you're aware of the materials that go in
again another kind of self-consciousness
or self-reflexiveness well Hitchcock
belongs in that tradition I think and a
great many of his mature films have this
double plot right the second plot is
that what we might call the drama of the
watching the drama of watching and rear
window is a particularly austere and
brilliant instance of this of this topic
well let me start over again with shadow
of a doubt set the context it's world
war ii is going on I already mentioned
that Hitchcock had already felt
ambivalent about leaving England at the
end of the 1930s and now by 1943 this
this anxiety because the war was on
England was being attacked
Hitchcock felt ambivalence about that
his mother was tremendously ill he kept
receiving information and she couldn't
get back to England because the war was
going on you couldn't travel there and
he was it was said that he was afflicted
by it but by a kind of really deep guilt
and unhappiness during the filming of
shadow of a death and
during the filming of shadow of a doubt
his mother died now there are some film
critics who say oh well the poor with
this one critic who who writes that the
portrait of the mother in shadow of a
doubt his Hitchcock's last benign
portrait of a mother but if this is a
benign portrait I I'm very nervous about
what is what is a mean portrait and it's
a very it's a very bad mistake I mean it
can't be that Hitchcock was trying to
memorialize his mother in the primary
character in this film because as you'll
see she's she's a magnificent airhead
she's she's the only Dumber woman in
film that I know is Annabel Lee in in
the general who sweeps out the engine
while while while they're trying to
escape their enemies and as you'll see
she I mean she's a figure she's a benign
figure in the sense that she has no not
a mean bone in her body but she's really
a dullard she's really silly and she's
silly in ways the film is aware of we'll
come back to that so so there are
elements in the film of autobiography
but they're skewed by Hitchcock's own
sour cynical disturbed nature and this
portrait of a family is very far from
being a celebratory portrait as we'll
say in a moment so Hitchcock's in exile
he's feeling a bit sour he's feeling
alienated so he makes a film in which
really his first film or one of his
first films in which an American family
is at the very center of the story right
but but he treats this family with an
odd kind of comic irony or any distance
that that a careful viewers immediately
see and lazy viewers might not see but
the careful viewers definitely see and
one way to pick up on how subversive his
portrait of the family is is to compare
him to his great comrade the
contemporary Frank Capra
I've we've seen a Capra film already of
course that what that that that a
standard an establishing screwball
comedy but the more characteristic Capra
films all these kinds of films were also
coming out at the same time or even more
fundamentally celebrations of American
life and maybe the the quintessential
instances of this is a film that anyone
who lives in the United States for a few
months around this
around Christmastime become sick of
what's the film starring Jimmy Stewart
who was also the star of of tonight's
Hitchcock well what if tonight's
Hitchcock filled the rear window what's
the film it's a Wonderful Life yes and
in fact the title tells no cup Capra
although there is a dark side to Capra -
but Capra's the great American
sentimentalist and optimist he
celebrates small-town virtues celebrate
and the villains in Capra's films are
big business and people who are hostile
to the values of small-town America
Hitchcock and and one way of
understanding what Hitchcock is doing in
shadow so I feel like it's a wonderful
life also incidentally these films often
starred Jimmy Stewart James Stewart the
guy but when Hitchcock uses James
Stewart this this this upstanding a
perfect example of Middle American
decency and American honesty is turned
into a much more fearful damaged
impotent sometimes sexually perverted or
implicitly sexually damaged adult it was
Hitchcock's version of Jimmy the Jimmy
Stewart that Hitchcock draws out is a
much more disturbed and damaged
character and part of what makes
Stewart's performances in Hitchcock's
film so powerful there's some people who
say Hitchcock and Stewart's
collaboration was one of the great
collaborations between a director and an
actor in America in the history of
movies and you could see one great
example of it in rear window but but but
the primary thing to recognize is that
what Hitchcock is doing something so
subversive because Jimmy Stewart was
already a kind of American icon he stood
when he came when he except in
Hitchcock's films and it he stood for a
form of American decency and openness
and honesty and sincerity goodness and
even heroism which Hitchcock undermines
in all kinds of I don't mean that they
make that he makes Jimmy Stewart an evil
character he doesn't and he gives him
his outwardly heroic lineaments but then
we discovered that there are things
wrong with him as you'll see in in in
rear window and he and he does this
again in vertigo
an even more dramatic example of Jimmy
Stewart playing and impaired or a
damaged character in rear window Jimmy
Stewart has one leg that's broken right
into the cast and for all the filming
and then bite when the film as you'll
see but the feel after them at the very
end of the film one of the outcomes of
the film is what in the in the dana mall
we see Jimmy Stewart after the action
has occurred and now he has two broken
legs so so he's back where he was in the
beginning is even more damaged and
impaired and immobilized than he was
before and we'll come back to this
because there's something very
disturbing about this ending in a
certain way even though it purports to
be a kind of survival tale I had in that
sense a a kind of happy ending but the
important point for the moment is that
Hitchcock was certainly fully aware of
the fact that what he was doing was
juxtaposing his much more sour
unsentimental even cynical vision of
American life against Capra's more
sentimental one right so he's a kind
it's as if he's against Capra or he's
against Capricorn the corniness get to
get the pun
I'm stealing I'm stealing it but the
corniness the sentimentality of of the
characteristic Capra film and the and
the characteristic attitude in the Capra
film toward small-town American life and
one of the ways to recognize this is to
recognize a kind of recurring trope of
his that I've mentioned before let's
show it Kristen so here is the opening
of the shadow of a doubt of giving you a
chance to watch it and then savor it the
second time when you see it again in 20
minutes or so in a half an hour or so
and it dramatizes a scene a version of
which occurs in many Hitchcock films
watch what happens in which the the
effect of the opening is in some sense
to implicate the reader the viewer right
at the beginning in an act of wire ISM
see a benign seen a benign cityscape
we go up to the window we in psycho it's
even more dramatic the film actually
crawls under a window shade that's
almost all the way down but you see what
the camera did okay stop when we first
see young Charlie in the film many many
scenes later what we've just looked at
will be replicated shot by shot you know
it's an example of what I call rhyming
scenes and I'll come back to that in a
moment so be behind any door or window
is potential evil and the way that the
way that we go out in the street then
then the camera looks up at a window
then it goes implicitly through the wind
and as I say in some Hitchcock films the
slithering through the window is
actually even more explicit and you
actually feel that the camera has slid
in as if as if it's a kind of unwelcome
and and and and unobserved witness to
the event and and the implication is
that you are that that you're watching
something that you're not that you
shouldn't be watching or that you have
access to worlds that normally you would
never have access to so behind any door
or window in Hitchcock's world can be
evil danger fright an American town an
American family I've already mentioned
that one of the things that's going on
in this in this film is a portrait of an
American family that has a kind of
ironic undercutting built into it we can
we can feel it we can feel it almost
from the very beginning when we first go
to Santa Rosa our first shots of Santa
Rosa which will occur shortly after the
scene you've just seen you'll see
there'll be a more elaborated scene in
which we learn a little bit more about
Uncle Charlie and then we shift to Santa
Rosa and the very opening scene in Santa
Rosa shows a sort of fat jolly policeman
in bright sunlight directing traffic as
if nothing could be more wonderful than
the job of directing traffic in a small
American town in sunny California what
could be more noble but there's
something excessive about it I mean you
almost feel even before you fully
realize that what the film is going to
be doing you sort of feel that this is
too much
and this this is characteristic of
Hitchcock as well is that almost as if
there's an excess of brightness and
excessive jolliness as if it's as if
it's more than we could possibly believe
and well and then as the family's nature
begins to unfold to us what we begin to
see is these children are horrible
insipid children they're hardly
admirable the daughters a nasty little
[ __ ] who is more interested in reading
her books that in speaking civilly to
her parents the not young Charlie but
younger but Charlie's younger sister
there are three children in the family
Charlie's the oldest right the the the
the the and then and then there she has
a sister and a younger brother and the
younger brother and the sister are
insipid nasty little children the boy
when we see him is constantly saying
what pret when he first sees uncle
Charlie says what have you got what
president have you gotten for me and and
if and if we don't think that the
children are very attractive wait till
we look more closely at the fact
appearance I've already mentioned the
father who spends most of his most of
his time with Hume Cronyn trying to talk
about ridiculous diversions in murder
mysteries meanwhile his family is
endangered around him and he doesn't
have any sense of it but the wife as
I've mentioned also comes across as one
of the supreme airheads in American
movies there's a certain moment when the
uncle Charlie is under suspicion so some
FBI agents come to town on in disguise
and they proclaim they suspect him but
they don't have evidence yet so they
they claim they're from a magazine and
they come into the family they say what
we want to do is we want to do a story
about a typical American family and the
mother of the family is very proud oh
isn't it nice to be a typical
representative of America well who would
want to be the mean right we're the mean
we're the norm right we are the typical
but but she loves this idea and then not
only does she love the idea
she she's really rather a silly person
so at one point when they're getting
ready to sort of I don't know whether
they're getting ready to do still
photography and the house she insists on
completing her cooking because she wants
to finish the pie before the
photographer gets there as if completing
her cooking has something to do with
what the photographer would find and
you'll find repeatedly that
she's kind of a little askew she
certainly has no possible intimation
that her brother is a murderer and and
in fact a cynical nihilist who has no
respect for anything in life and she
never learns any better and that's part
of what makes the film so disturbing so
what happens in the course of the film
essentially is that this this American
family is systematically shown to be
sort of silly and foolish banal in its
ordinariness hardly something that we
might philemon I don't mean to say that
where we come away in horror or thinking
oh wow disgusting this family is just
that we think how ordinary banal silly
foolish it is one of the ways that we've
talked about all I've talked already
about the way in which Hitchcock is
obsessed by doublings and by the idea of
a self divided and one of his richest
treatments of that theme is in the
treatment of uncle Charlie and young
Charlie and you'll see how explicit the
film is about that one of the ways it's
explicit about it is that check is that
Hitchcock uses particular visual
strategies to reinforce the connection
and I've already mentioned the rhyming
scene in that opening scene watch it
because it's quite exciting later when
we in our first introduction to young
Charlie the camera behaves identically
to the way it behaved when we saw uncle
Charlie and even so even before Uncle
Charlie has entered the story even
before we're fully aware of what the
relationship between uncle Charlie and
young Charlie is the camera has told us
that they are linked we and we could say
them that in the doubling young Charlie
represents a kind of innocence and part
of her night but one way to understand
the film is to see it as a as a
bildungsroman as a growing up as an
initiation story in which young Charlie
learns about learn something about the
evil and difficulty of the world she has
a naive and simplified view of the world
and before she's done she comes face to
face not just with murder but with with
the possibility of murder and in fact
uncle Charlie actually tries to murder
her and it went because he realizes she
knows the truth about him
so she's in danger for part of the film
and knows she's in danger and part of
the issue is that you can't really talk
about it why not
it's her uncle have you ever heard this
kind of there are actually critics who
say that although that it's never made
explicit in the film that one of the
ways to understand the film in at least
in the subtextual way is to think about
the relation between uncle Charlie and
young Charlie as that between the sort
of perverted uncle who who man handles
his young niece when when it when his
family isn't watching right and there
actually is in this in in the film of
what is a scene sometimes called a
betrothal scene in which we see uncle
Charlie we see young Charlie come down a
staircase like a traditional bride down
a staircase and uncle Charlie gives her
a ring so the film doesn't them and
that's really perverse the film doesn't
actually say to any kind of anything
sexual is going on between uncle and
niece that's not but there are there are
these suggestions of illicit or
disturbing connections that are that are
that are part of the subtext in which we
with which we experience the film and
with in which with which we recognize
the the tangled disturbing quality of
the connection between young Charlie and
her uncle so the naivete on young
Charlie's part is her failure to
understand or TV to be able to imagine
the extent of evil and duplicity in the
world and we could say that what happens
as she's she as she comes to recognize
what uncle Charlie really is or what
uncle Charlie really stands for she is
educated into the ways of the world the
the but it is but it is in many ways a
very terrible and and very serious
initiation and one of the climactic
instances of this occurs toward the end
of the film when young Charlie and her
uncle meet together in a you know in a
bar called the I think it's called the
till - because it's closes at two which
is very late didn't in in the in the
universe of the film 2 a.m. is very late
in Santa Rosa California
I mean they mean in this place and this
is where Charlie saw that baby uncle
Charlie realizes he can no longer hide
the truth and he talks openly to you to
young Charlie and he says at one point
this we're old friends Charlie more than
that we're like twins you said so
yourself you think you're the clever
little
who knows something there's so much you
don't know so much you're just an
ordinary little girl living in an
ordinary little town you hear the
contempt for ordinary there Hitchcock
shares some of this even though his
villain is saying it right you go
through your ordinary little day at
night and you sleep your untroubled
ordinary little sleep filled with
peaceful stupid dreams you live in a
dream these are this is a direct
quotation you live in a dream you're a
sleepwalker blind how do you know what
the world is like do you know the world
is a foul sty do you know that if you
rip the Front's off houses you'd find
swine the world's a hell what does it
matter what happens in it now what an
extreme nihilistic statement right
that's what Charlie that's what uncle
Charlie stands for that's the full
ugliness and disturbance that young and
of course a murderer is speaking to her
this is also implicitly a confession
Terry yes I have killed people right so
it's a tremendously disturbing moment in
the film and it represents her in a
certain way
young Charlie's coming of age but the
but the irony or one tremendous irony of
this of this tale of this of this story
is that when we get to the end of the
film there's a profound kind of
ambiguity yes
the evil has been purged I won't go into
the details of the plot so as not to
spoil your experience of the film but
Uncle Charlie is eliminated from the
scene in a and young Charlie survives
it's a kind of reassuring or happy
ending but what undercuts it as all
remember all of Hitchcock's endings are
undercut they're never really happy
they're never really reassuring they go
through the motions they're
conventionally reassuring but they're
not the moral ambiguity on which the
film ends is maybe it's most disturbing
aspect because what does what what it
says because young Charlie never tells
her mother never tells her father never
reveals to the community that uncle
Charlie was this evil figure was the
married widowed murderer why not well
maybe she's sparing her mother uncle
Charlie's no longer there what's the
difference there's no discussion of this
but what does it mean it means that when
the film is over the idea that evil
might lurk at the heart of the American
family remain
a reality that no one has acknowledged
in other words it's as if it's as if the
implications of the story are denied by
Charlie silence and we're left in a
situation at the end of the film in
which the implications or meaning of
Uncle Charlie's life has been suppressed
and therefore the significance of his
pervasive nihilism and of what it means
that such nihilism could exist at the
heart of a typical American family is
never acknowledged or known by anyone
inside the film even though it's a
disturbing knowledge that we take away
from the film so to conclude on this
film one of the things to think about as
you're watching the film is how
remarkably Hitchcock is able to give us
what might be thought in many ways to be
and what is in many ways a light
entertainment a humorous and very
well-put-together mystery story about an
American family and and and full of wit
and and and scene by seeing richness and
complexity a film that that that even
naive film goers can enjoy fully and yet
the full implications of it the moral
ambiguity with which the film ends and
the moral ambiguity that's really
implicit all the way through the film
the sense of the ominous and the
disturbed the disturbed the sense of
disturbance remains remains with the
viewer after the film is over and it's a
characteristic way of Hitchcock for
Hitchcock to end films rear-window as
I've suggested is an even more rigorous
exploration of some of Hitchcock's
deepest preoccupations and obsessions
let me remind you to really savor the
opening scene of the film it starts
under the titles I mean yet the title
sequence and under the title set it's a
it's a it's a sequence that last three
or almost four minutes and it's
completely wordless there is no there is
there are there's no dialogue watch how
much what happens and it's it's a it's a
it's a complicated moment in a certain
in a certain way but if you're if you're
attentive to it you can you can see
what's happening essentially what we see
the camera do
first first we see the blinds go up on
on to wind on on open windows and then
we realized that their open windows
their casement windows that are open
unscreened right and after the blinds
the camera is stable the plug the blinds
get doesn't move the blinds go up one of
the three separate Brunn's well they go
up one at a time they reveal they reveal
on the other side of an apartment
complex being seen through the window of
another apartment and then what we see
the camera then goes on in sort of
elaborate journey it's a you and there's
nothing you're you're caught in the
camera's gaze you're as a viewer you for
the camera then the camera then once the
shades go up then then you then the
count then then the camera begins to
move it moves toward the window then it
moves out the window and then it looks
down and it does a kind of circuit of
the essentially it shows you what can be
seen from this window it does a kind of
circuit of the of the of the of the of
the physical spaces that are open to it
if it looked at this world from this
window and you see it gonna make Olga
make its make it make a kind of circle
it's not a 360 degree turn but it's more
than 180 the camera turns like this it
pan it turns around and then it comes
back in and then it comes back into the
room and when it comes back into the
room it come it goes out of the room and
it looks around and then it comes back
into the room through the same windows
backs up further and you see Jimmy
Stewart lying there sweating in the heat
the camera then goes look looks up the
wall a tan thermometer and you see the
thermometer is hovering in the mid 90s
someplace explaining why Jimmy Stewart
is sweating so much
but then the camera moves outside again
and does another circle of the space
that you had just looked at is almost as
if it wants you to look at it a second
time to remind you of the space of the
action of the film and of course we
don't fully realize it at them at the
time but this is a rehearsal for the
whole movie because we are going to be
confined in exactly this way for the
entire film we're never going to get out
of this room everything we see will be
seen through this window right then the
camera come pulls back in again we see
Jimmy Stewart again so it's almost as if
that opening sequence does does the same
thing twice what it mostly does of
course is trap the viewer in an act of
wire ISM it
traps the viewer completely in an act of
spying and then almost the very first
words of the film the camera pulls back
it looks at a few items that tell us a
little more about the fact that Jimmy
Stewart is a photographer who works for
a magazine who was injured taking one of
his action photos he can't wait til he's
out of his cast but he has another week
to go and he's going stir-crazy while
he's and then he has a conversation on
the telephone with his editor and then
after he and and at the same time he
engages in various acts of wire ism
including especially a young woman who's
scantily clad across the across the
courtyard in her room wearing us we're
wearing a shorts and a very revealing
brassiere doing sort of exercises and so
forth while she's eating her breakfast
and you see the Jimmy Stewart character
of wire istic Lee savoring her as he's
talking to his to his friend and then
then he hangs up the phone knock comes
on the door a woman enters it's his
cleaning lady played by the great
character actor actress Stella
what's-her-name Thelma Ritter Thelma
Ritter and Thelma's almost almost first
words are we've become a nation of
peeping toms and I mentioned this just
to show you how aware the film is how
much the film wants us to be aware of
the fact that wire ism is one of its
deep subjects right why do we have this
desire to watch the illicit what is it
about us that wants to make us sort of
look through keyholes and peep at people
and watch the intimate lives of people
and so the opening scene is a scene that
dramatizes the confinement and the
voyeurism that are at the very heart of
what the movie is about we can say that
the whole essay the whole film in some
sense is a kind of essay on seeing and
in that three or four minute sequence in
the beginning without dialogue the
camera is the star in a certain sense
but where we become aware of the camera
as Hitchcock wants us to be in a way we
would never be in another kind of film
there are other forms of elegance in the
film and I hope you'll watch the way the
camera behaves because it's a it's a
marvel of complexity and intelligence
but there's another way in which there's
an elegance of structure in the film as
the cat
in the very beginning makes its tour of
the building we begin what begins to
emerge in a very elementary way at first
and then as the film proceeds becomes
more fleshed out is that there are three
or four basic stories about people who
live in the apartments that Jimmy
Stewart is looking into and each of them
tells a separate kind of story there's a
story a Miss Lonelyhearts story about a
woman who's pining for a boyfriend and
who feels very lonely and maybe toying
with the idea of suicide then there's a
story about a composer who so who's
who's having trouble with his work their
series of sort of subplots mostly
trivial ones except for the primary one
what's the primary one a murder may have
been committed in one of the apartments
that Jimmy Stewart has been prying into
and he begins to investigate the murder
and that puts him in danger himself and
the people involved with him including
his girlfriend Grace Kelly get involved
in the danger as well because he's the
immobilise to be the one who walked
across the way it does so so uh um
the elegance of the structure of the
film has partly to do with the way in
which these subplots work themselves out
and at the end of the film each of these
little subplots that we'd seen being
played out in these different apartments
only watching them through the windows
of the apartments each of them is
resolved in some way and I want to
suggest you that their resolution while
from one sent from one angle is very
satisfying there's a kind of code
there's a kind of elegance of structure
we're very satisfied by this sense of
completion but at the same time I think
the very fact that these stories are all
tied up in such neat knot makes us feel
if there's something a little too neat
about it a little too little too perfect
about it in other words the very
perfection with which these subplots are
tied up at the end suggests a kind of
excess that Hitchcock wants us to be
suspicious of is everything this is just
too perfect and of course there are
other ways in which the ending of this
film is deeply ambiguous and I'll come
back to that in a moment
III also ought to mention the way in
which in a quiet subtle way this film is
an exploration of both class and gender
issues because there's a kind of little
sort of contest going on Grace Kelly
who's this elegant upper-class woman who
you know has gets her fit gets her
clothes at the fanciest fashion stores
and
has food delivered from the catered from
the fanciest restaurants in the city and
who reads magazines like Vogue and so
forth she stands for sort of moneyed
elegance and and and and there's a kind
of tension between them she wants to
marry Jimmy Stewart and Jimmy Stewart's
resisting one reason is that he's he
doesn't belong to her class he's more of
a working-class type right he's a he's a
down-to-earth sort of guy and he's
worried about that and he's also nervous
because like many American males
especially in the movies he's nervous
about being entrapped by marriage as if
he isn't already entrapped in all kinds
of ways and and in an odd kind of way we
could say that the Torvald marriage
that's the name of the murderer and the
the wife he supposedly murders and chops
up at least that's what Jimmy Stewart
comes to suspect we could say that the
Torvald marriage is a kind of double of
the of the marriage that that the Jimmy
Stewart character fears he will have
that his resistance to Grace Kelly is
partly a resistance a class resistance
he doesn't he doesn't sort of he feels
uneasy about around this aristocratic
woman because her tastes seemed to him
banal and trivial and in any case they
seemed to him to to involve values and
commitments that are at odds with the
sort of rough-and-tumble life of a
traveling photographer who goes to war
zones and other dangerous places but
that's his image of himself and he said
and so he so so his resistance to her is
partly a resistance to it's partly a
desire to maintain his freedom right and
and it's partly a class issue so that so
that so that both issues of class and
gender are involved the gender issue it
has to do with how different groups how
men and women especially in the
stereotyped way of the 50s and 60s
regarded the question of marriage right
and and there are other marriages or
relationships that are alluded to in the
in the film and we could say that those
marriages and relationships also double
the relationship between Stewart and
Kelly so there's a kind of low level not
exactly hostility but a low level
badinage and and argument going on
between Kelly and Stuart all the way
through the film which is in some sense
resolved but not fully resolved or
resolved in a typically unsatisfying
Hitchcockian way at the end of the film
so after yet so the very ending of the
film then okay that but there is the
tradition though the murderer as caught
is exposed the danger to which the Jimmy
Stewart character was exposed is purged
by the end again I won't go into details
if you've not seen the film but I need
to say this much in order to explain the
ending and at the end of the film as
I've said there's a moment where we see
him he's a he the murderer finds out
that he's watching him and after a while
he comes to Jimmy Stewart's apartment to
try to parently to try to murder him
because he thinks he's gonna reveal who
that he's a murderer himself and it's a
terrifying scene the great climax of the
scene stewardess his his his physical
limitations some critics have seen as a
as a symbol as a symbolic embodiment of
what might be seen as a form of
impotence both are sexual impotence and
a sort of broader kind of impotence and
incompetence because he's crippled he
can't fight he can't defend himself he
can't behave like a traditional man in a
traditional movie right and again
remember this is characteristic of
Hitchcock his men are almost always like
this it's amazing in fact how weak
vulnerable damaged fearful frightened
his his protagonists are so there's this
climactic moment at the end where
Torvald the murderer is trying to kill
Jimmy Stewart and he pushes him and
Jimmy Stewart is holding on he's on the
second story window he's holding on like
this looking at the cameras looking down
at him you see the fear and horror in
his face he lets go there's a critic a
brilliant critic of french critic who's
talks about the idea of letting go of
losing your grip as a central action in
Hitchcock's films you lose your grip and
you fall into a void and that moment
that is an eye as I said this afternoon
could be said to be an iconic moment in
Hitchcock's movie so when Jimmy Stewart
actually lets go and Falls you see his
face he's for as if he's falling to his
death
you think he might be falling to his
death but of course he's not he just
breaks his other leg and at the end of
the film then we have a final scene and
this is where the ambiguity comes in we
see him with both legs now he's backward
was but the Grace Kelly character is
sitting happily in the room watch that
she pretends that she's reading material
that would please Jimmy Stewart but in
fact if you look closely she has a copy
of Vogue hidden inside the material that
she's reading and there's a very deep
sense that in this gender conflict
between Grace Kelly and also we discover
at the end that they're now engaged so
so Jimmy Stewart has become engaged to
this woman
right so it's it's almost as if he sort
of lost the battle or at least he's
agreed to marry but what we feel at the
end is that his agreement to marry her
is still full of the same ambiguities
that were present before it and and many
people watching the film have said you
know the Grace Kelly character is very
beautiful and very elegant but she's not
a very attractive person morally she
tries to manipulate the Jimmy Stewart
character she doesn't seem fully to
appreciate him she wants she doesn't see
why he wants to run around the world in
corduroys and sneakers instead of living
the high life in in New York and go and
going to the cirque for dinner she can
understand truly understand and so the
conflict between them is a kind of
lifestyle conflict at the end of the
film none of those things have been
resolved and there's there's the sense
that he's more in track than ever at the
end of them at the end of the movie now
I don't want to make too much of this
remember this is a light entertainment
at one level but these subjects that
I've been talking about this sense of
losing your grip of being caught in a
confined space and being terrified by
forces far larger than you that you
can't that you're too weak or damaged to
resist those moments of horror and
terror are dramatized with profound
Authority in this remarkable film
so what Hitchcock repeatedly does and
especially in these two films and you
see them in that if you can see them in
a conversation with each other you'll
understand more fully the fascination of
Hitchcock's career the fascination of
his works because he keeps returning
with these remarkable variations again
and again to the same set of to the same
set of problems and of subjects so
there's even more ambiguity and
uncertainty at the end of rear-window
than there was when it began and one
final point
stop one of the things that we notice in
the course of the film is there's one
moment in the movie when the Grace Kelly
character is suddenly where the Jimmy
Stewart character responds to Grace
Kelly with a kind of excitement and
allure it's almost a moment where you
see he suddenly really desires her
really sees her as a possible partner
and it's the moment in which she has
entered the voyeuristic drama
it's the moment in which he's watching
her through his lens when she's gone
across to try to do some detective work
in the murderers apartment and there's a
kind of excitement and adventure that
goes on there you could and it's
actually the moment when they blitt when
they bond when they real and and there
is some sense that they're both engaged
in a morally exciting in a mutually
exciting adventure but there's also the
sense the very disturbing in a way when
you reflect on it later that the moment
in which Grace Kelly became truly
attractive to the Jimmy Stewart
character was the moment in which she
had entered the voyeuristic drama in
which Kelly Kelly was now distant from
in which he was he was attracted to her
because he was seeing her as if he were
a peeping tom
so now this is a subtext I don't mean
that that I don't mean that the film ism
is is using a megaphone to remind us of
these of these implications but the
number of them billed through the course
of the film
and as with shadow of a doubt what seems
on the surface to be a kind of light
diversion once we begin to press its
details becomes a much more disturbing
and powerful meditation on our human
impulse to watch what we're not supposed
to watch to participate in illicit
activities without being punished for it
especially if we like Jimmy Stewart are
able to do so in the dark and in that
sense when we step away from rear window
one of the things we might recognize is
that we in the audience have been
engaging in the same activity that Jimmy
Stewart is engaging in in the movie that
we are complicit as viewers in the
immorality and in the end in the
murderous tendencies of these forms of
entertainment so it's not possible if
you are an alert and self-conscious film
goer to watch these apparently like
these apparent
entertainments without recognizing their
deeper and more disturbing implications
you